Hi meine Süßen!
Heute gibt's einen Zitronen-Cheesecake mit Zitronensoße,
total lecker und frisch, passend zum Wetter.
Und ihr hab mir dabei geholfen! Ich hab nämlich gerade auf Instagram abgestimmt,
ob ich jetzt was mit Zitrone oder was mit Kirsche machen soll.
Und das Kirschrezept, das kommt dann irgendwann.
So,  und ich fange jetzt hier auch direkt an, ich schnacke gar nicht großartig drum herum.
Wir brauchen für den Boden Butterkekse und Butter.
Und ich habt jetzt hier die Butterkekse schonmal fein gemahlen.
Ihr könnt da auch einfach ein Nudelholz nehmen und draufhauen,
hauptsache sie sind fein.
Dann geben wir geschmolzene Butter dazu und verrühren das.
Und falls ihr euch wundert: "Wo stehen denn die Mengenangaben?",
die findet ihr alle unten in der Videobeschreibung.
So, einmal verrühren und dann nehme ich mir gleich auch schon meine 24er Springform,
den Boden schön mit Backpapier auskleiden und dann den Keksboden schön andrücken.
So der Keksboden ist jetzt in der Zwischenzeit einfach im Kühlschrank,
lagert den einfach dort bis es weitergeht.
Und ich hab jetzt hier meine Zutaten bereitstehen, benutze die Küchenmaschine.
Ihr könntet alternativ auch mit ganz viel Kraft einfach mit den Händen und mit 'nem Schneebesen rühren.
Und ich hab jetzt hier zuallererst Magerquark, ich fang jetzt auch schon direkt an.
Ich geb einmal Magerquark rein in die Schüssel,
dann nehme ich gerne etwas Doppelrahmfrischkäse.
Ich finde das in Verbindung mit Magerquark schmeckt total cremig und nicht so trocken.
So, das ist jetzt drin. Frischkäse wie gesagt,
nehmt hier keine Light Variante, tut mir den Gefallen!
Das ist ganz wichtig, dass ihr einfach nur Doppelrahmfrischkäse verwendet.
Und Sahne, die dient nochmal der Cremigkeit.
Damit's einfach nach dem Backen auch richtig schön cremig ist.
Und dann süße ich das natürlich mit Zucker und bei meinen Zitronengebäcken kommt immer Vanille rein
weil ich finde, dass das super harmoniert!
So, Zucker und Vanilleextrakt und dann kommt schon unsere Zitrone zum Einsatz!
So, jetzt ist es ganz wichtig wie ihr eure Zitronenschale reibt!
Erstens muss es eine Bio Zitrone sein.
Ihr möchtet ja nicht die Schadstoffe aus der Schale haben sondern es soll komplett unbehandelt sein.
Und dann ist es wichtig was für eine Reibe verwendet.
Ich nehm jetzt hier meine Feinreibe, damit macht ihr überhaupt nichts falsch.
Damals - ich musste auch erst die Erfahrung machen -
damals habe ich einfach die Vierkant-Reibe genommen, die ich auch für Salat etc. benutze,
und dann hatte ich nach dem Backen richtig dicke Zitronenschalen-Stücke im Gaumen
und dann war der ganze Kuchen versaut.
Daher spart da bitte nicht und investiert in sowas.
Und dann noch ganz, ganz wichtig: es gibt Bio Zitronen, die sind einmal so groß
- hier hab ich sogar die Endstücke abgeschnitten - und die sind so klein!
Also ihr habt solche und solche, die sind total individuell.
Und deswegen mache ich euch am besten Esslöffel-Angaben
damit falls jemand, der so eine Zitrone hat, nicht sagt: "Der hat mir gar nicht zitronig genug geschmeckt!"
und jemand der so eine hat sagt: "Boah, der war viel zu sauer der Kuchen!"
Deshalb genau Esslöffel-Angaben, damit mache ich glaube ich heute nichts falsch
und dann presse ich jetzt einfach noch den Saft rein.
(H: Das war jetzt richtig wie in der Schule, fand ich total interessant!)
Ja, informativ!
(H: Also das wusste ich selber jetzt nicht!)
Oder?!
(H: Spitze! Noch mehr davon!)
Gerne, gerne!
So, anschließend noch die Eier dazugeben und dann alles langsam verrühren,
bis es sich verbindet. Das dauert ungefähr 1½-2min.
Und ganz zum Schluss rühren wir dann noch Speisestärke ein, die ich zuvor siebe
damit  wir keine Klümpchen haben.
Und jetzt ist der Teig fertig und wir füllen ihn einmal in die Springform, die ich gerade aus dem Kühlschrank geholt habe.
So, einmal schön einfüllen und dann kann das auch schon in den Backofen.
Ich verrate euch auch schonmal die Backzeit - ne, die Hitze
180° C Ober- und Unterhitze, ganz wichtig: Bitte vorheizen!
Immer vorgeheizt backen und zwar für 50min, das kann auch 2-3min länger oder kürzer dauern.
Wichtig ist, dass ihr es dann anschließend richtig schön abkühlen lasst.
Und dann zeige ich euch jetzt, wie ihr die Zitronensoße macht. Also bis gleich!
(H: Und du hast da was vergessen!)
Wo?
(H: Da ist was hier drin!)
Jaa....das wollte ich doch jetzt hier ausschlecken!
Geier!
(H: Ja aber nicht dass es da weiß ist nach der Aufnahme, damit's schön...)
Damit's schön flüssig ist. Aber heute sind wir einfach mal spontan!
So, zufrieden?
(H: Ja, jetzt kannst du den Rest nehmen!)
So, den Rest darf ich aber ausschlürfen hier, auslecken!
(H: Ja!)
Super! So, bis gleich!
So, für unsere Zitronensoße habe ich jetzt vorab erstmal Zitronensaft ausgepresst
und weil der sehr, sehr sauer ist nehme ich natürlich auch Zucker zum Ausgleich.
Ich geb direkt Zitronensaft und Zucker hier einmal in den Topf, der Herd ist noch aus.
So und da kommt noch Speisestärke dazu.
Das soll ja nicht sehr flüssig sein sondern eher halt soßen-mäßig, so ein bisschen sämiger.
Auch mit dazu.
So und dann einmal unter Rühren aufkochen lassen und dann dickt es schon ein.
Und ganz zum Schluss geben wir eben auch für die Konsistenz ein bisschen Butter mit dazu.
Kleiner Trick vorweg: ich geb da jetzt ein bisschen Lebensmittelfarbe rein,
damit's auch ansehnlicher aussieht.
Alternativ könntet ihr natürlich auch Orangensaft z.B. nehmen.
So, die Zitronensoße jetzt einfach auskühlen lassen.
Und wir müssen ja sowieso noch auf den Kuchen warten bis er auskühlt.
Am besten schmeckt er wenn er richtig schön im Kühlschrank war,
ihr ihn dann aber 1/2h vor dem Verzehr aus dem Kühlschrank nehmt.
Das ist mein Top-Tipp für euch.
Und dann gebe ich euch hiermit die Kiki Garantie, dass euch dieses Rezept schmecken wird,
wenn ihr Zitronen-Fans seid und Fans frischer Torten.
(H: Weißt du was?)
(H: Ich lasse so ein Zertifikat hier einblenden)
Jaa!
(H: Wo draufsteht Kiki-Garantie!)
So richtig mit Stempel! Kiki-Garantie!)
(H: So!)
Ja das wäre toll, wenn du das machen würdest!
So, ansonsten wünsche ich euch jetzt ganz viel Freude beim Nachmachen.
Wir müssen uns ja hier jetzt auch noch ein bisschen gedulden damit das abkühlt.
Und ich denke mal auf Instagram seht ihr dann den Taste Test von Hamza und mir.
Folgt uns gerne auf Instagram damit ihr dort auch nichts verpasst
und auch wie hier mitbestimmen könnt, was so alles schönes online kommt.
Und dann würde ich mal sagen sehen wir uns bei meinem nächsten Rezept hier auf Kikis Kitchen!
Tschüss!
Boah, der schmeckt echt zitronig!
(K: ZU zitronig?)
M-mh!
(K Also frisch.)
Diese Soße macht's halt richtig zitronig!
(K: Ja wir haben ne Zitronensoße ja drüber gemacht.)
Hey, das ist voll sommerlich!
(K: M-hm!)
Das passt jetzt voll zum Wetter!
(K: Perfekt!)
Geil, echt!
(K: Und ist der mächtig, oder..?)
(K: Oder geht's?)
Sieht man ja! Also mächtig ist ja wirklich, wirklich... -
Aber der ist jetzt trotzdem ein bisschen mächtiger finde ich.
(K: M-hm!)
(K: Perfekt!)
Ich find's lecker, voll lecker echt!
Ich hab's nicht bereut, mehr Zitrone reingemacht zu haben und mehr Sahne.
(H: Aber das passt voll zum Wetter, ne?)
Passt richtig gut zum Wetter!
Hey, wir müssen das vorziehen! Wir müssen das eigentlich diese Woche schon hochladen, nicht nächste.